[Music]
what is bipolar disorder the word
bipolar means two extremes for the many
millions experiencing bipolar disorder
around the world life is split between
two different realities elation and
depression although there are many
variations of bipolar disorder let's
consider a couple type one has extreme
highs alongside the lows while type two
involves briefer less extreme periods of
elation interspersed with long periods
of depression for someone see-sawing
between emotional states it can feel
impossible to find the balance necessary
to lead a healthy life type ones extreme
highs are known as manic episodes and
they can make a person range from
feeling irritable to invincible but
these euphoric episodes exceed ordinary
feelings of joy causing troubling
symptoms like racing thoughts
sleeplessness rapid speech impulsive
actions and risky behaviors without
treatment these episodes become more
frequent intense and take longer to
subside the depressed phase of bipolar
disorder manifests in many ways a low
mood dwindling interest in hobbies
changes in appetite feeling worthless or
excessively guilty sleeping either too
much or too little restlessness or
slowness or persistent thoughts of
suicide worldwide about 1 to 3 percent
of adults experience the broad range of
symptoms that indicate bipolar disorder
most of those people are functional
contributing members of society and
their lives choices and relationships
aren't defined by the disorder but still
for many the consequences are serious
the illness can undermine educational
and professional performance
relationships financial security and
personal safety
so what causes bipolar disorder
researchers think a key player is the
brains intricate wiring healthy brains
maintain strong connections between
neurons thanks to the brains continuous
efforts to prune itself and remove
unused or faulty neural connections this
process is important because our neural
pathways serve as a map for everything
we do using functional magnetic
resonance imaging scientists have
discovered that the brains pruning
ability is disrupted in people with
bipolar disorder that means their
neurons go haywire and create a network
that's impossible to navigate with only
confusing signals as a guide people with
bipolar disorder develop abnormal
thoughts and behaviors also psychotic
symptoms like disorganized speech and
behavior delusional thoughts and
paranoia and hallucinations can emerge
during extreme phases of bipolar
disorder this is attributed to the
overabundance of a neurotransmitter
called dopamine but despite these
insights we can't pin bipolar disorder
down to a single cause in reality it's a
complex problem for example the brains
amygdala is involved in thinking long
term memory and emotional processing in
this brain region factors as varied as
genetics and social trauma may create
abnormalities and trigger the symptoms
of bipolar disorder the condition tends
to run in families so we do know that
genetics have a lot to do with it but
that doesn't mean there's a single
bipolar gene in fact the likelihood of
developing bipolar disorder is driven by
the interactions between many genes in a
complicated recipe we're still trying to
understand the causes are complex and
consequently diagnosing and living with
bipolar disorder is a challenge despite
this the disorder is controllable
certain medications like lithium can
help manage risky thoughts and behaviors
by stabilizing moods these mood
stabilizing medications we're
by decreasing abnormal activity in the
brain thereby strengthening the viable
neural connections other frequently used
medications include antipsychotics which
alter the effects of dopamine and
electro convulsive therapy which works
like a carefully controlled seizure in
the brain is sometimes used as an
emergency treatment some bipolar
patients reject treatment because
they're afraid it will dim their
emotions and destroy their creativity
but modern psychiatry is actively trying
to avoid that today doctors work with
patients on a case-by-case basis to
administer a combination of treatments
and therapies that allows them to live
to their fullest possible potential and
beyond treatment people with bipolar
disorder can benefit from even simpler
changes those include regular exercise
good sleep habits and sobriety from
drugs and alcohol not to mention the
acceptance and empathy of family and
friends remember bipolar disorder is a
medical condition not a person's fault
or their whole identity and it's
something that can be controlled through
a combination of medical treatments
doing their work internally friends and
family fostering acceptance and
understanding on the outside and people
with bipolar disorder empowering
themselves to find balance in their
lives
[Music]
you